Hello and welcome to fire learning.
Thomas Jefferson was one of the founding
fathers of the United States of America.
He authored the declaration
of independence,
served as America's second vice
president and it's third president.
Aside from his political roles, he was
also a man of science and philosophy,
being curious of the entire world around
him in his very long an eventful life.
He left us with quite a bit of advice on
both a personal and national level and
in this video we're going to share
that advice. Keep in minds, however,
these are Jefferson's quotes,
not necessarily ones which I
personally agree or disagree with,
so let's get to it.
Number 10 the most valuable of all talents
is that of never using two words when
one will do.
Jefferson had quite a bit to say,
but he was remembered for being a quieter
man in his many years of politics.
He encountered a lot of bloviating and
useless talk and he had no interest in it.
When he spoke or when he wrote,
he was very much the points and
a declaration of independence.
Where she authored is a document
that perfectly portrays this.
It is very much to the point number nine,
history in general only informs
us of what bad government is.
The United States was a nation which
did not only go to war to become an
independent nation.
It's war of independence was also,
and probably more importantly
to most Americans,
a war fought to embrace new ideals
that were less common in Europe,
which was primarily ruled by monarchies
or in England, a constitutional monarchy,
plain and simple. Thomas Jefferson
did not like government and in fact,
majority of founding fathers shared his
opinion that government should be as
limited as possible because it and
their view typically worked against his
subjects or constituents.
The founding fathers disagreed
on where that line was exactly,
but Thomas Jefferson is indeed on the far
end of the bunch in terms of disliking
government.
And number eight,
timid men prefer the calm of despotism
to the tempestuous sea of liberty.
Jefferson did not believe that once
the war of independence was over,
that freedom would be
an easy road from there.
Americans today have a proverb that is
similar to this. Freedom is not free,
but most Americans do not understand this
to the extent that Jefferson did as he
had lived in a time when that freedom
was not guaranteed and was hard one
liberty,
he believed with something that must be
guarded from accrual and wild world on
all sides by individuals,
not something that has rewarded
after a single struggle.
Only strong people that were willing
to constantly defend their freedom.
We're going to keep it.
He believed. Number seven,
I sincerely believe that
banking establishments are
more dangerous than standing
armies and that the principle of spending
money to be paid by posterity under
the name of funding is but swindling
a futurity on a large scale.
Jefferson is essentially saying that
working yourself into debt with the
expectation that a future generation will
pay it off is a very bad idea and that
banks pose a greater threat
to nations than army to do.
Jefferson believes that the
habits of European nations,
including those that economics,
we're not necessarily models be followed.
Jefferson argued against
things like a national bank,
and in fact even claim that
each generation should be
expected to pay off their
debts within 19 years worth pondering
and modern America's economic situation.
Number six determined never to be idle.
No person will have occasion to
complain of the want of time,
who never loses any. It has wonderful how
much maybe done if we're always doing.
Jefferson did a lot in his life and he
wouldn't have gotten so much done if he
was not a productive and efficient man.
Jefferson believes that a good cure to
feeling like you never have the time to
do the things that you want to do is
to make use of all your time and never
waste any. If you want something done,
get to doing it as simple as that.
Number five,
if a nation expects to be ignorant
and free in a state of civilization,
it expects what never was and never
will be. Jefferson, and in fact,
many of the founding fathers
openly spoke about their opinion,
but a people's wellbeing was inescapably
tied to the level of education and
intelligence.
He believe that freedom of speech opened
the doors for things like education and
ideas and such things to flow
more freely on their own.
But he believed furthermore that,
uh,
people should make an effort to better
themselves with an education as a means
to safeguard their freedom and longevity.
Number four,
I never considered a difference of
opinion and politics and religion and
philosophy as a cause for
withdrawing from a friend.
Jefferson had very strong political views
and he regularly encounter people with
whom you strongly disagreed.
He helped fight a war over a political
disagreement and yet still in his
personal life, other people's
politics, religion or philosophy.
We're not necessarily what constituted
a good person or friend and Jefferson's
eyes.
Sometimes people just think differently.
And Jefferson had the ability
to respect that. Number three,
do not bite at the bait of pleasure
until you know that there was no hook.
And he said,
this is Jefferson's advice for an aspect
of the human condition that we are all
sometimes guilty of a,
we do things in the moment that feel
good that we'll have longterm negative
consequences and be when
someone promises us good.
We may at times over look the potential
bad and it is the latter part of the
Jefferson focuses on more specifically
a king may promise us prosperity and
wealth for our generation.
However,
establishing a monarchy in long run may
in Jefferson's opinion be detrimental
for generations to come that do
not share in that prosperity.
Number two,
I hold it that a little rebellion now
and then is a good thing and as necessary
in the political world as storms and
the physical Jefferson does not like the
concept of a system which maintains an
indefinite prosperity because he doesn't
think it's realistic.
He believes that the political arena has
to be shaken up quite a bit regularly
in order for freedom to be maintained
as it's just another part of life.
He even somewhat hinted the notion
that the American government,
which he helped found would in time change
in forum and begin to encroach on its
citizens,
and Jefferson suggested a
regular revolution would
keep this inevitable attempt
on people's freedoms and check number one,
do you want to know who you are?
Don't ask.
Act Action will delineate and define you.
We all of course wonder what it means
to be who we are in many different ways.
But Jefferson says that our self is
not something that we searched for and
eventually find,
but rather something which we create.
Oftentimes we may be looking for a path
in life when the best path is the one
that we have to build ourselves and
the paths that we ourselves build and
Jefferson's eyes to find us as
individuals. Jefferson, of course,
despite being a quiet man,
had much more to say,
but these are some of his most profound
and celebrated quotes from what we do is
like this and videos
on many other subjects.
Be sure to check out fire of learning
and subscribe. Thank you for watching.